for russian-born canadian constantine
stollov helping war victims in ukraine
is very personal i have a two-year-old
son
and
16 years
16 years later he will ask me
what did he do to stop it when stoloff
heard about russia's invasion in ukraine
in late february he decided to start
fundraising for the victims on facebook
i feel that it is my
country which is on their own side now
right so i need to help
ukraine so far he has raised twenty
three thousand dollars canadian and
plans to keep going it's money that
victor hepman chuck says those fleeing
violence can put to good use they need
everything if you're escaping you're not
taking your food with you you're not
taking any people cannot get their
medical attention i'm getting calls
every day i'm stuck in this airport help
the canada ukraine foundation was
established in 1995 to help coordinate
community projects in ukraine over the
last two months hetman chuck says
they've been using donations to provide
basic needs like food shelter and
medications adding there are many
trustworthy organizations trying to help
but the efforts won't stop when the war
ends
[Music]
organizations will be needed to rebuild
communities lost in the war
charming somani global news